there's no secret mac and cheese is
loved by everybody but when it comes to
black households mac and cheese takes a
whole new meaning we are serious about
mac and cheese and it has to be at every
single holiday celebration so today
kenneth and i are actually going to have
a nice friendly competition where we are
going to test each other's family mac
and cheese recipes to see whose recipe
is superior you ready let's do this here
all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
so now it's time for me to school mikko
on how to make this new orleans mac and
cheese this is exactly how my mom and i
made it my grandmother used to make it
and taught my mama then my mama taught
me and after i got out of coloring art
school i got past the torch so mikko let
me show you how it's done now that we
have our boiling pot of water let's take
that lid off for them okay okay now
let's add some salt and we want our
water to taste like the sea so don't be
doing two cute little pinches go ahead
on and put some salt in that water once
it comes back up to a boil it's time to
add our noodles and i noticed that
you're using spaghetti noodles though i
ain't never seen that before that's
right respect my culture
we use spaghetti in new orleans i don't
know why that's just how i was taught
that's how my mom and them did it so
that's how we do it traditionally in
black household we don't play with the
noodles it's like you keep it real
strong with the elbow you might do small
elbow you might do large elbow right i
ain't never seen this so this is very
unique we want them nice long strands of
noodles okay cook this for six minutes
and then after that we're gonna drain it
but we're gonna keep moving after this
one sounds good we need to make a room
and that's because of the french
influence to louisiana especially to new
orleans so the first thing i need to do
is i need you to cut your skillet on to
a medium medium high you want to add
your butt melt that down we're going to
make this room which is going to be
equal parts of fat and flour with this
cheese sauce you want to use butter so
that rich velvetiness comes through not
using oil like you would with a gumbo so
we can get that real deep fried of flour
so you mean to tell me in your household
your family was making a french bechamel
sauce is that what you're telling that
is not what i'm telling you
what i'm telling you is after i got out
of culinary arts school this is what i
started doing ah okay okay now that our
butter is melted now we're gonna add our
flour and just go ahead on and stir that
on up that roux looks perfect now
let's get ready to add our spices and
herbs so we're going to add some salt
we're going to add some black pepper
we're going to add some garlic powder
and we're going to add a little bit of
that gang that cayenne that is i love to
add the spices to my root so it could
toast all of those spices and wake up
all of the flavor once you make this
you're literally gonna get kissed with a
little bit of love i literally smell it
just really went up my nostrils right
now
that's what you want that means you're
doing it right now let's add our half
and half and we're going to add it in
thirds and the reason we add it in
thirds is because we want to make sure
that we cook out all that flour don't
nobody want no mac and cheese that
tastes like flour that just ain't it
baby that just ain't there you're going
to kind of whisk this for about 1 minute
to 30 seconds just depending on how high
you got your 5. once you see where it's
thickening up if this is your sign that
you should start adding your next bit of
half and half what i do see is a lot of
seasoning floating around this sauce
which is promising to me because that
means there's going to be a ton of
flavor absolutely oh yeah we ain't
lagging on them play about your baby you
know i mean we may be doing things a
little bit unconventional but flavor is
definitely the mother of this sauce
during the cream too okay so you have
half and half and heavy cream why are we
adding both of those well i like to use
half and half instead of whole milk
because it's half milk half cream so it
gives it more flavor and then you got to
add the cream just for that extra a
richness as you're waiting for your
liquid to come up to a ball you want to
make sure that you whisk it stir it
occasionally just to make sure that the
flour doesn't begin to burn as it sticks
to the bottom of the skillet now that we
have our liquid boiling it's time to add
our cheese you can have all the fun you
want with add whatever cheese whatever
ratio you want but for this one we're
going to do three cheese go ahead on and
add some cheddar some sharp cheddar
swiss whisk okay now add some pepper
jack you just grab all of the
and whisk that on up and cut it off
that's it that is your cheese sauce okay
let's bring this dish together all right
so our spaghetti is finished cooking so
we're going to go ahead on and add that
to our casserole dish so now pour your
cheese sauce over okay okay get it all
in there we want that thing swimming
how did i do it
great that looks pretty good to me you
look good all right now that you got
your cheese sauce go ahead on and stir
it so that all the noodles fill the love
because you don't want no dried noodles
in there and this is the point where you
just you know trying to even it out see
how good it looks it's nice and saucy up
in here that's what i want make sure
it's nice and even okay so i'm gonna
kind of flatten it out like that we have
our bowl of cheeses yes these are the
remaining cheeses right instead of doing
it individually i like to keep them in
one bowl and mix them up okay go ahead
and give it a little toss down okay one
big happy one big happy cheese cheese
family
so go ahead on okay and make it rain
[Music]
no cheese left behind now it's
completely up to you how much cheese you
add to it how much you don't we already
got a beautiful cheese sauce but it's
mac and cheese so i gotta be cheesy here
we go how's it look it looks fantastic
[Music]
all right kenneth that was easy to make
now it's time for you to make my mac and
cheese
we are about to prepare my mama's deep
dish mac and cheese now let me tell you
something this is the dish that my mom
is assigned at every cookout she is the
official preparer of mac and cheese
because of this recipe that's big i
already had you prepare my elbow noodles
okay because mac and cheese requires
elbow noodles so those are already
cooked up and they've already been
drained what i need you to do now is add
some butter this is going to coat all of
the noodles so that they don't stick
together now we are going to make what
is the comparison of your cheese sauce
it's not a bechamel my mama didn't have
time to make a bechamel she was the
mother of four girls she needs to move
quickly so we are going to make a sauce
that's a little bit different starting
with some sour cream that's going to
give a nice tart flavor but add some
creaminess to the mac and cheese and now
we're going to add some cottage cheese
in my opinion this is the only place
where i use cottage cheese let's move on
to our shredded cheeses so i want you to
add some sharp cheddar cheese add some
smoked gouda some good stuff right now
it is some good that's actually a new
addition my mom just recently fell in
love with that so that's a new addition
to her recipe okay uh pepper jack grab a
little bit of that add some fresh
mozzarella now i'm gonna have you add
the canned cheese sauce that's going to
add an extra level of creaminess to the
mac and cheese add some evaporated milk
for me that's a lot better than using
traditional milk or half and half
because it has less water in it so it's
going to help that melting of the
shredded cheese okay and now it's time
to add our seasoning so we're going to
go with some salt pepper garlic powder
onion powder and cayenne pepper so mix
that all really well make sure it's
fully incorporated you want to make sure
that all those flavors are blended
before we add it back to our elbow
noodles yeah this definitely looks night
and day compared to my cheese sauce my
mom doesn't even know what a bechamel is
for heaven's sake so she only used what
she had around what was in her pantry
what was in her fridge these are
everyday ingredients to achieve a creamy
sauce and it works i love it yeah that
whole cottage cheese thing is a whole
different
game change it adds texture it's a
texture component that looks pretty good
and that's it that's all it takes to
make this cheese sauce it's super simple
now is the time we start adding our
cheese sauce to our pasta i need to
taste it just to see what we're working
with all right
that's unique
tell me more because it got the
tanginess from the sour cream and
cottage cheese but then you get all the
nice spices behind it so that's why it's
unique
all right now that you've tasted it
let's go ahead and add that sauce to our
pasta and stir it very generously making
sure that it's all incorporated you want
to make sure that all the noodles are
coated everything has a little bit of
sauce on it nothing should be there no
noodle left undone our next step is to
add some eggs so i want you to whisk up
this egg and add that to the pot and
this is a really good time to add your
egg because at this point your macaroni
has been cooling a little bit you've
added your sauce which is cooled it down
you don't want that macaroni to be hot
when you add your egg or else it'll
start to cook the egg and that would be
all bad so yeah that looks really great
look at look how pretty that looks we
haven't even baked it yet right it
looked creamy right yep
yes it does it looks amazing he's so
shady okay that looks incredible it's
time to move on to our next step add
this mac and cheese into a pre-greased
casserole dish large elbow macaroni is
the type of macaroni that will allow the
cheese to go inside the noodle okay so
you're not just getting cheese on top or
surrounding noodle it's actually in the
middle of the noodle so cheesiness is
everywhere that is super important i
want you to take all the cheese mix it
up all together get it all incorporated
go ahead and add that on top be generous
yes all over it
but that's what your favorite thing is
how i feel when i see cheese i don't
know i can't help it the last step i
want you to cover it with some aluminum
foil since we didn't make a bechamel
what this is going to do is help keep
the heat within the pan insulate and
help melt down those cheeses
everything looks great you can truly see
the difference in the mac and cheese
family yours got their traditional
creamy brown bits mine has that all over
golden brown crusty edges but
everybody's delight i love how i can see
the spices like all throughout so you
know it's going to be packed with flavor
and the creaminess is just like oozing
out like if you just press it and see
the creaminess like oozing out you
really caught that good new orleans bob
because see ours is more about sauciness
and cheesiness well thank you so much
and i'm actually really impressed by
what you've done you actually got the
creaminess that i was looking for and
you got those bubbly brown bits that i
love on the top of my mac and cheese so
good job so far let me take a little
bite first
the thing that's really interesting
about this is how creamy it is but how
little of goater you use and how
dominant of the flavor that good is to
this whole dish pretty damn good mac and
cheese that means a lot to me thank you
chef
i really am not mad at this spaghetti
noodle it's actually quite delicious
particularly because you can get cheese
sauce like all around the entire noodle
that's exactly why i use the big elbow
macaroni and so the cheese sauce fully
covers everything my favorite part the
crusty cheese stuff it goes well with it
it's delicious now let's test each
other's to see if we lying to each other
or not i know i did you right let's see
how you did me right
[Music]
so good you did a real good job this
here just reminds me of home so much and
now all i need is just something to wash
this down with now that we've done the
taste test we have to decide which one
is the best i am very curious did you
change your mind can it which mac and
cheese rein supreme i would have to say
that i have not changed my mind i'm
going to keep it new orleans 110 percent
oh nobody could ever top my mama's mac
and cheese okay now my mama's back at
you this is my go-to this feels like
home this is what i grew up on i will
always pick mama's mac and cheese so i
love your mac and cheese it was
delicious but mama mama yours raising
supreme all right guys so i guess that
means you guys are gonna have to decide
which mac and cheese is the best so go
ahead leave a comment down below let us
know or tell us what makes your mac and
cheese so special so you can always find
me mikko in the dish on instagram and
you can find me at kenneth temple
underscore on the ground until next time
y'all peace
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]
you